C,
重疾险有必要买吗？
一年6400块钱，
可以回答我一下吧，
这个事儿呢，
我只能说我自己是买过的，
我自己是买的，
我买的重疾险七七八八加起来的话，
具体交多少钱我还真是忘了，
但是我记得我的保额啊，
我的重疾险的保额可能有个80万，
就如果我得那些重疾的那些范围之内的话，
可能赔我80万，
我其实我不光买重疾险，
我原来不是没有现在这个条件那么好嘛，
我现在条件好了，
我可以管我爹妈的生养死葬，
把衣食住行全都管了，
在我原来条件没有那么好的时候，
我大概30出头的时候，
我给我自己是买了这种寿险，
寿险什么意思呢？
万一我走在前头，
我爸妈他们能拿到100万，
可以给他们养老，
这是我对父母表达一种感恩孝敬的一个方式，
因为我这个人比较疏离，
这个疏离也不是说我自己非得疏离，
因为我从小就离爸妈比较远嘛，
12岁就不在爸妈身边了，
所以我跟爸妈之间没有那么多话可聊，
没有那么多就拉拉手啊，
抱一抱啊，
亲一亲啊，
没有那么亲密的行为。
但是在我的心里的话，
我对爸妈的这份感恩，
就是我为你们铺好路，
就是这个世界上我在或者不在，
我的父母都不会被人欺负，
我的父母都能够安然的养老，
这是我对他们的孝敬。
呃，
就是说我收了80万，
不是说我一年要花80万去交这个钱啊。
一年可能就交个8000~1万多吧，
是两个保险，
加起来我有80万的保额，
这个保额是什么意思呢？
就是如果我真的出现了那个重疾，
那么他就先把钱打给我，
这个是他的保额是80万，
我不是说我每年花80万，
那没有，
刚刚有人说菲菲你好孝顺，
也谈不上孝顺，
我感觉就是父母子女一场的话，
图一个圆满，
图一个互不亏欠，
有谁能懂我这个典型的吗？
就下辈子能遇到挺好，
下辈子要是遇不到也没有什么遗憾啊，
就这么个关系啊，
在哪个公司买的，
那就不太好说了，
因为我没有这个资格推荐，
我就涉嫌那个推荐什么金融机构了，
这个是违规的，
记得点赞关注哦。